Ihr Herren und Frauen,
die ihr einst Kinder wart:
Er steht auf diesem Platz,
der Ahn hat's schon gekannt,
was ihr hier seht:
Christkindlesmarkt genannt.
Und wer da kommt,
der soll willkommen sein.
Auf diesen Moment haben Tausende
in Nürnberg gewartet:
Der Christkindlesmarkt ist
offiziell eröffnet!
Die Besucher kommen
wegen Weihnachtsschmuck,
Nürnberger Lebkuchen,
Rostbratwürsten
und einer Tasse Glühwein.
Aber erst der Auftritt des Christkinds
macht den Markt perfekt.
Das ist einfach so eine Kindheitserinnerung,
oder einfach für Kinder
schon immer schön gewesen.
Und es ist jedes Jahr einfach
wieder was Besonderes,
wenn der Prolog gehalten wird.
Wir sind extra deswegen gekommen.
Es ist schön, einfach unglaublich.
Man wird wieder zum Kind,
und das ist doch das Schöne hier.
Wenige Stunden zuvor:
letzte Vorbereitungen für das Christkind
– ganz ohne Kostüm und Perücke.
Die 19-Jährige Barbara Otto spielt
die Rolle schon zum zweiten Mal.
Doch von Routine kann
keine Rede sein.
Das ist ganz unbeschreiblich.
Man steht dann da oben,
die Menschen unten warten auf einen.
Irgendwann geht das Licht an und
man freut sich einfach total,
dass es jetzt wirklich losgeht.
Darf das Christkind rein?
Naja ...
Bitte!
Na gut ... Hallo.
Für die Tonprobe geht es
auf den Balkon der Frauenkirche.
Alle zwei Jahre wählt eine Jury
aus vielen Bewerberinnen
eine junge Nürnbergerin als Christkind aus.
Zu den Aufgaben gehören nicht nur
der Auftritt heute,
sondern mehr als 150 Termine
in der Vorweihnachtszeit.
Die Herausforderung für Barbara Otto:
trotz Zeitdruck immer
himmlische Ruhe bewahren.
Die Aufgabe als Christkind ist, den
Menschen Weihnachtsfreude zu bringen,
den Menschen ein bisschen die Ruhe in
den Weihnachtsstress wieder zu bringen.
Das Christkind gehört seit Jahrhunderten
zum deutschen Weihnachtsfest.
Es bringt den Kindern an
Heiligabend die Geschenke.
In manchen Regionen Deutschlands wurde
es inzwischen allerdings
vom aus den USA importierten
Weihnachtsmann verdrängt.
Der Weihnachtsmarkt dagegen wurde aus
Deutschland in die ganze Welt exportiert.
Keiner ist so berühmt wie der in Nürnberg
– mit immer demselben Erfolgsrezept:
regionale Spezialitäten und Handwerkskunst.
Das Christkind wurde als Wahrzeichen des
Marktes in den 1930er-Jahren eingeführt.
Bei Kleid und Perücke machen
Kostümdirektorin Eva Weber
und ihre Kolleginnen am Nürnberger
Staatstheater keine Experimente.
Die Materialien variieren ab und zu
ein bisschen, aber das Modell als solches,
und die Sternchen drauf und so,
nehmen wir eigentlich von dem
vorherigen Modell und wir denken,
das ist einfach ein Markenzeichen.
Und auch, wenn die Mädchen
sich verändern,
das Kleid als solches soll immer
wieder wiedererkennbar sein.
Zurück bei Barbara Otto:
Sie ist in Kleid und Rolle geschlüpft.
Vor der Kirche wird das
Christkind schon erwartet.
Hier sind so viele Kinder da,
da sind so viele Wunschzettel.
Mit denen möchte ich jetzt
auf jeden Fall sprechen,
die Wunschzettel mitnehmen,
damit ich auch weiß,
was ich euch allen zu Weihnachten
wünschen … äh,
zu Weihnachten schenken darf.
Ich hab meinen Wunschzettel bei mir
ins Badezimmer gehängt
und du hast den dann heute
Nacht abgeholt.
Ja, den habe ich schon bekommen.
Den habe ich schon geholt heute Nacht.
Und während die Kleinen
ihre Wünsche loswerden,
können die Großen auf dem
Christkindlesmarkt schon mal einkaufen,
was an Heiligabend unter dem
Weihnachtsbaum liegen soll.